[Applause]
we go back oh we're getting close you
ready to race sorry grant so I'm really
excited for this Becca's gonna get a
drive a race car but the funny part
about this whole thing is six months ago
my dear sweet wife suffered a serious
nerve injury giving birth to our
youngest child because of that she has
not been allowed to drive for six months
like a week ago she went and did like a
little test drive with our minivan they
kind of see if she is good to go
this will be your real your first real
driving experience in six months won't
it yeah way to jump in the deep end of
the pool baby I'll just go check it out
the dodge charger hellcat I believe I
actually really wanted to drive one of
these things but there's no way I'm
fitting inside elaborate you pull look
at this this car doesn't even come up to
my waist side down
hey Tommy what do you think is that
pretty cool
[Music]
couple Ferraris oh look another Ferrari
so we'll go do a couple laps around and
watch red drive drive same question now
the name of the game is you're driving
around the same for the green coat to
break the orange slow in ready go fast
did you like it
sure okay
hey daddy a good look at that look at
that race car fancy Becky you're making
helmets so sexy right now and me and
Tommy will be up on the observation deck
I'm her entourage classy let's go
you giving mommy some last-minute
coaching remember Becca remember
everything we learned from watching
Ricky Bobby just go like the wind
now we're not allowed to videotape
inside the car they've got cameras of
their own in there but me and Tommy can
go up to the observation deck here watch
mama go around the track here I'm so
glad to see her doing this I was so
worried she wouldn't be able to get
behind the wheel you know it doesn't
matter how fast she goes as long as
she's having fun I think she's having a
ball there's there's mommy in the white
car Tommy
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah there's mom a good adorable slow
white speck in the horizon
[Music]
holy mackerel
there we go awesome
what you think Becca was that allows the
bud you look great out there babe did he
see Tommy cheering yeah he was jumping
up and down screaming go mama go
you look great Becca
[Music]
I like being a fast woman
great day you look great if you liked
this video don't forget to check out our
2018 World Tour where we spent five
weeks traveling all over Asia and North
America and having all sorts of great
adventures it's a twelve part series and
is absolutely amazing so don't forget to
click Subscribe for more adventures from
the outro boys YouTube channel and click
the link below to see more videos from
this trip